the EU digital coverage certificate is a  European success story that has gone  global  but it has really been a key tool in  order to facilitate safe travel  during one of the worst pandemics of  modern history when citizens everybody's  lives changed  the most important I believe lesson that  we learned is that we can achieve truly  remarkable things when we work together  when we coordinate and when we cooperate  the European health data space which we  proposed earlier in May for ourselves as  a game changer in the area of Health let  us see how this will will affect  citizens lives  in in actuality first of all we citizens  having full control of their data in a  in a protected way fully protected way  will have access to their medical file  including their Imaging their tests so  that they can access health services no  matter where they are within the EU